Hello and welcome to this course Python Integration for Unreal Engine 5.5.
So our goal for this course is by the end of it you should be able to understand how to
create your own script for Python that runs inside of the Unreal Editor.
We'd also like you to understand its limitations and some of its common use cases.
We are going to spend quite a lot of time looking at the different methods of triggering Python
scripts. Python scripts can do a whole load of different things but how you actually go about
triggering it is probably one of the more important things to understand. We'll also
talk about how to get data in and out of Python and have a look at making a framework
for building pipeline tools and we're going to provide you with a whole bunch of different
example tools that can be deconstructed so you can see how something like this might work.
So how we're going to do this is we're going to start off we're going to have a short chat
about theory. So we're going to talk about custom tools within the engine and then we're going
to have a look at a lot of the setup and the documentation of how Python is connected
into the engine and touch quickly on the different integration methods.
Then for the majority of this course what we're going to do is we're going to go over
five different examples of how you might set up a tool that's used in Python. So thank you,
that's it for our introduction video. Next we're going to be jumping into some of the theory.
Thank you very much.